bene quando si chiamerà the crisi
ultimamente non si può difendere ma
anche studiato rai con sa concas 2008 i
test seri su 2008 certezza
diciamo
la bancarotta della lehman brothers
lehmann brothers la grande banca
d'affari o su chi vede america è appunto
tasse tossico ed enia da intro a un
certo punto resta esplode
su che sul serio su 15
settembre su 2008 in realtà di nomadi
cambiato made a xavier da cosa non sta
messo immediato babù mio sindaco esausta
di andata tra ballack stadi dopo uguali
in nostra impresa in salsa commenta am
unificante in grado di produrre produci
valori dei beni del fai servizio
esattamente i commenti evidenziata prima
che gusto seuss ed esili ma la domanda
che si sono posti sul naso in sù 2008
quando si comincia a pensare a sarre
decs e proprio gusto e possibili kawa
crisi che partita della finanza la crisi
ricadi travolge dotto su chi è su
credito sta situazione su credito e
banca sull uscio su bay aver lavello
anti sarà il grifo sito e su credito c'è
su credit crunch in sardegna a benito
già della situazione che aveva su credit
crunch quindi non è vero super freddo su
prova di descrisse a situazioni poco
mentasti ma questa crisi ha detto la
crisi di talmente in manna che è il
numero sul 10 16 punti ma i blues 28 su
900 che hanno sabina bloomberg bloomberg
e tanara da narada che gli
stati uniti d'america anti spendi la
bellezza di 7 mila 700 miliardi di euro
potrà mai sul sistema bancario ma età
punti 7 mila e 700 miliardi di euro su
pallosu caso sono abituato a file sconto
su un pauroso donna mesi centinaia di
euro su e difficili a sedurre immaginai
bene passionali un piano detta e step
costo questo salvataggio sia lo nega la
spesa fra umana che sono stati uniti
anti fatto in toto sta storia cosa e
soro è stata seconda guerra mondiale 360
miliardi sul dollaro su che è che il
nostro d'uso da rosa valotta i bulls
inflazione ai muri punti di 3.600
miliardi su circa poi ribassati 1.700
miliardi su the pausa aggiungi la guerra
in corea sa guerra in vietnam su di noi
può mandare supremo means all'una e
ancora hanno ucciso sarah e basso costo
panna e canta emana gusta critiche stati
investiti e non su
chiaramente in san sisto su domanda sul
tavolo fi no su installa cosa nostra pp
che destano st sardinia così qaida in
modo che l'azienda sa credit crunch anno
credit crunch
potenti continuare a
randy ea comprare e quindi a po di
donare traballo e appoggi traballa e
enza s'immagina su un sistema che sarde
e sarde è un sistema che permette alla
sua azienda sta tesi finanziare in
maniera reciproca su una cosa tra quindi
attraverso su sistema ad hazard ex miss
impresa tentò la linea decreti tu noi in
moneta normali noi è un main sarde usar
decs balli documento euro ecco sto punto
azienda volti interesso circuito è
acquistare sui decreti di ponevo su
computer spendi dei mille euro su in
credito su quindi suo conto casa sua
andata meno mille credito su ai questo
punto it à deux pd vai no da pd fai
altro che ha ben di sugli sci fi il
prodotto che produci di il proprio
servizio su altra impresa adesso
circuita tutto posso proprio valori
poeta gusta linea di credito è stata
allo zero che hanno interesse poi
tradito concentrato sugli interessi sui
rendita sarà poi ti rendi tarzan aradam
studio da economista da destra iniziare
a margate kennedy punti sa causa
maggiori dei diseguaglianza sia in su
mundu poeta su 90 per cento della
popolazione paga di interesse sul sud e
c.so don casa la
stessa domanda ma noi di aic
buona gestione in banca mio nantes
interesse giocando domando quindi vanta
in realtà di 110 poi pagando un naso
comprato un prodotto o servizio
il costo su finanziario su tanti fatti
del su prezzi e quindi da ogni nota che
il nostro compravo sulla causa interesse
a chi pagato interessi a sud a cipro
cento della popolazione
poi c'è un'altra cosa si commenta in
questo sistema polonia credito certo
debito
ok kid è un incentivo chiede di credito
ad saboterà i primus super star e potrei
rendita la scheda è subito non ad
apparire mai pagare sue pidoux insardà
exxon abeni poeta chi riesca in debito
giovedì sarà da pagare ottava gara in
beni e servizi e paga la conta cosa
gallery dove disse invece che the credit
uso 1b di storia del d'uso spendi volta
poeta si nunc accessi inflazione che si
vada il cosiddetto potere d'acquisto ai
questo punto è un plauso a fai un
network dell'impresa sarda sa si sono
scontrati subito con
questo suo che italia sezioni tanti
luoghi comuni sulla
susa giardina di e sardo sono punti
bonus ora collabora e poco sulla così
mal unidos ed usura uno show su lotus
iter now
io pago pago chi invece sla secondo
un'oasi saggio su punti bonus e commenta
a collaborare eroga stiamo in svizzera
accesso sistema commenta su uno
strumento assai beck 6 punti adesso 34
vaden di 265 mila piccole e medie
imprese svizzere
utilizzata donne a di subire questa
moneta cosa in soru poi vai scambio è
una moneta toto sessantina è mai sardo
sono fonti svizzero è una soddisfazione
a 6 ma manco svizzero punti sardos
e quindi si sa opposto esatto di
comprendi che chiaramente a s'iniziano
estetico semplici le piazze ormai un
network di azienda ed ottenga
all'azienda 60 usa che su primo contatto
8 una bella mè è da costruire a chi
senso contesa d'uso e deciso commentato
abela bello si punta giunta se impresa è
mai se non noi snai cup è sempre a punti
1150 interessante che hanno funto enormi
dati mano.il manco vago su costasse
impresa dentari anti scambia ora a
utilizzai euro quindi kennedy rai anti
scambia alla bellezza di 10 milioni di
euro su dei valori e servizio su tre
milioni sestesi settimo esprima cento di
iside quest'anno con la crescita anno
dopo anno adesso 300 200 su quindi o
indaga sul sistema chiaramente
commentato se si sta in mezzo ad arezzo
si è cresciuti esponenzialmente il cons
man mano che all'on pinti no no fase
impresa poeta toto i redditi noti
salvezza adesso un mondo pensato a sud l
fono a si iniziò quando c'è pago gente
non ti amerà bella anno pensava ubaga
menu cia finizio non sa nulla e resiste
la pianta ad assago sia sostanza il
letto della stanza eletta sacro g a noi
che ci vesti di auto gusto spazio molti
punti 7 miliardi su della persona di cui
cine fonte assume anche un miliardo
cadenti o smartphone quindi con lei
connetti su 24 ore su 24 a a su web
quindi su valori doretti cresciti mamma
oca che recentissimo numero suo numero
despar sano sa che da utilizzata ma
commenti serna è nasce a costiere fa con
canotta e ho subito sicuramente tutti
esempi che ci punti ad esempio svizzero
ma ci fronte altro esempio sono in tutto
il mondo ma
va sottaciuta è uso studiavo la proposta
dell economista mete importanti forse si
son provando adesso nuovo centro che si
apre a john maynard keynes ormai john
maynard keynes su 44 a bretton woods
rapposto la sua proposal for
international cleaning union ovvero la
proposta devo circuito tra nazioni si
che funziona esattamente come ti
funziona lazar l'ex è una roma che dopo
diventate chiedo quanti variazioni situ
potevo subita dalla tarsu alla
situazione nostra e dovrò pause la prova
pozzo nike è andata bene non averla
belupo su tempo bene i tori è uso
pensato di allargare costretti fin se
sei dipendenti dell'impresa quindi
nocetti e bruce impresa mai dipendenti
pur età donante dipendenti xi da un anta
maggiore impegno don antonio anche dona
intruso st propria azienda e cadenti in
cambio maggiore potere d'acquisto in
calli modo
attraverso bene in fitto attraverso
bonus attraverso
anticipazione sui stipendio dei mesi
canta venni silva suo esempio così
comprende testi o dipendenti dell
azienda cosa nostra iscritta che sa di
domanda o anticipazioni a sud attori
della the traballo poeta de pia da
organizza sul matrimonio cosa sua da
tori da traballo da riina ma euro e un
occidente di espressi da oggi mille euro
deve donare posso matrimonio con un mio
no 28 enza de ven in con cana ma anche
di du sud da un gene credito su questo
10mila euro sulla su matrimonio andata
bene adesso dipendenti cia pensava di
gas di arssa lista dell'impresa sapeva
sul ricevimento c'è bombonera saci punti
ma dai si è fatto 10 bene studente
gustano esprimo mesi degustando un
matrimonio intero pagato tutto inserito
so che è una spending euro gusto e
importanti porta muri tutti impresa
talenti difficoltà di merda a donare
anticipazioni sia dona i bonus a
riconosci il sud raballo straordinario
poi cannuccia di liquidità ri ma
attraverso questo sistema sono in grado
de tornai a ripristinare dotto gusta
bella scossa sa che prima si variante
granta collaborazione e coesione tra
datori di lavoro e
dipendenti si sud ersu basso odiosa da
piva e muri è su ingresso dei cittadini
muso in noi pure sanna età donante
cittadino sua impresa donan tassa
proprio all'alta di commenta consumatori
si
hugo sma doride civili da spendi e
proprio euro su mezza azienda sa adesso
circuito adatte in cambio credito su da
spendi
all'interno del ferro e tradotto costo a
me lo sudo sconto voi perché dodi faccio
sconto voi due sui nati dalla rada in
bus h di spendersi noiosi andati compra
se lassù gratta e vinci è andata a
calciano in cui stamane era invece ad
itala dei famosi modo che su sconto di
20 di opportunità di due andrà fatto
abbiamo un'altra azienda in questa
maniera è azzurra a connetti impressa se
adesso d'arredo del suo territorio
poi tanta disconnette alla sua causa tra
troppo bit ikeda sapo po di asso vasa
affronta questa sfida della
globalizzazione
essa sfida due grandi grandi
multinazionali si cadrà ballata in
sardegna commenti in tutto suo mondo
quest'idea è stata talmente
apprezzata hanno scelto in sardegna ma
forse a destra sardegna punti nascendo
in tutta italia sul modello des hard ex
è una collaborazione nosta circuito
idonea regione dell'italia e nasce pmx
in piemonte è nascessi kanex in sardegna
e in sicilia fonti nascenti nelle marche
punti nascendo in abruzzo fontina scendi
in molise punti nascendo emilia romagna
secondo su piano chydenius ricadenti il
nostro collaboratori si in save niso la
cia dessi incontinenti a vela veloce
adesso circuito in donia regioni
costruita sarde questo progetto casi a
die zeit
sarde cso progetto fatto derby ciò che
documentano zoe che consiste the usa
fora santi blu su mundu e fonti don raso
posta questa esperienza sa domu soru e
dopo averla elaborata dal punti non
renda bottai il suo mondo sospetti uso
studiato della banca centrale
dell'ecuador usando file se uso in
contatto con il professore amato della
bocconi che fa tende su circuito a
nantes in via da sindico su primo
ministro francese air oltre questo
significa da che manca in sardegna e
manca in due
contesti che apparentemente non resti
avverso si dice in italiano unibet in
sardo ed innovazioni si
sentì fi è creare idee e progetti su
capo in test è sporta uso in forza
calessi soggettivo cosa nostra obiettivo
cosa non stavi adesso obiettivo da john
maynard keynes che su sottotitolo the
suddetta proposta cosa sua che poi fu
accantonata possa proposta the white
quindi valorizzazione del suo mondo
il suo sottotitolo via da e doppia che
contrappone ad aa utopia porta utopia
ordina e non luogo è utopia significa
luogo felice e nord ovest sardegna
diventi presto una terra felice